votre mission si toutefois vous
l'acceptez je me tais rage on avez vous
déjà reçu celle
non absolument jamais la fin que vous
redoutiez est proche
et c'est vous qui aurez ces morts sur la
conscience les conséquences de vos
bonnes intentions
vous avez pris une décision difficile
vies perdues pour en sauver des millions
cette fois c'est le monde entier qui est
en danger s'il avait gardé le plutonium
nous n'aurions pas cette conversation
toute son équipe seraient mortes
oui probablement ce sont les risques du
métier
[Musique]
tu ne sais pas de quoi tu t'es engagé
badens vite
combien de fois at il été trahi par son
ami désavoué mis sur la touche 1
combien se nomme communiqué supporter ça
avant de décider de ça suffit
[Musique]
alors comment il va tu sais comme on les
aime qu'est ce qu'il fait je crois qu'il
vaut mieux pas regardé